so Marvel's gang war is like the coolest
event that they have going on right now
that no one knows about so check this
out gang war is exactly what you think
it is it's literally just a giant War
among the various gangs in Marvel Comics
so a little bit of explanation here
right as most of you guys can probably
imagine the different Warlords that
exist out there or gang Lords whatever
you want to call them right the owl
Black Mariah Tombstone people like that
MST Negative they all have these kind of
like little territories here and there
that they basically Rule and for the
most part the alliances between these
guys were tenous at best and only for a
couple of reasons the first is because
of the Kingpin Wilson Fisk that when
this guy was like running the criminal
underworld nothing ever happened without
his purview right that with all these
territories that were ran by all these
gang Lords they all answered to Wilson
Fisk he ran the whole show now during
the story Devil's Reign which we covered
and we'll have a link to at the end of
this video Wilson Fisk became the mayor
of New York technically it happened
after the events of secret Empire but
during that time he made it illegal to
be a superhero in the city of New York
the public favored it it was one of
these things where he was just kind of
like think of all your friends and
family that have died in collateral
damage right like that kind of thing and
so the public voted against superheroes
operating publicly the other part of
this is that following the events of
Devil's Reign Wilson Fisk being outed as
the mayor of New York and Luke Cage
taking his place where Wilson Fisk ended
up going off and kind of going
underground and currently he's part of
the fall of X event it left his role
vacant which had been taken over by
Tombstone and where Tombstone had kind
of kept these things going for the most
part Tombstone was in effect quote
unquote killed not killed but kind of
killed right that would have gone on and
like Amazing Spider-Man number 38 is
that Peter Parker literally possessed by
evil Souls if we're being honest with
ourselves uh he had actually pulled the
plug on Tombstone after he'd been shot
he was effectively saved by the hospital
but it left tombstone's Ro vacant and
that's where gang war picks up that what
you have here is a guy named Hammerhead
who's kind of like running everything
the way the tombstone did and
everybody's kind of vying over the
question like who takes over tombstone's
territory now the cool thing about this
and this this is the reason why it's so
cool is because it's basically a
gigantic street level event right it's
awesome every street level superhero
that you know about is a part of this
which actually includes Shang Chi the
Shang Chi is actually operating within
the conf of What's called the five
weapon Society he's kind of a warlord
kind of not but he does have dealings
with criminal elements if you guys are
interested in that story we can cover it
because it's kind of dope that like
Shang Chi basically becomes a criminal
warlord it's pretty awesome but they're
all kind of arguing over what it is that
they're going to do now you could make
an argument why doesn't somebody just
take over tombstone's territory right
why doesn't someone like the owl or Mr
negative even why doesn't Mr negative
just go and take over tombstone's
territory because it would leave leave
him in a state of vulnerability say for
example that he does that right say for
example that that Mr negative just goes
and invades tombstone's territory where
you don't just readily do that because
there were criminals there who are still
loyal to Tombstone it would be a war he
would go to war against tombstone's
forces but while he's doing that it
leaves his territory open so someone
like sheni or Black Mariah could just
say well now we're going to invade like
Mr negative's territory and just take it
over and so again like it's one of these
things where it's all kind of ten
it's very very conflicting now what's
also cool about this is that Hammerhead
is here with the woman in his life right
the girl that he's just kind of banging
right at the moment and one of the
things that had happened up to this
point is madam mask had basically been
killed or at least it was believed she
was killed right off whatever you want
to call it now we don't know the details
about it whether she's alive or dead and
Madam mask has not historically been an
overly important character but she's
always been a cool one and so it's kind
of this discussion of how there's a lot
of interest and a lot of intrigue going
on with like Madam mask who was recently
offed and now Hammerhead is taken over
this role so on and so forth so it looks
like he's just kind of playing the
criminal game and manipulating things in
his favor which he is the cool thing
about all this is Janice shows up now
why does Janice matter Janice is the
daughter of Tombstone right like Janice
Lincoln right the daughter of Lonnie
Lincoln and the cool thing is that
Janice had been dating a guy named Randy
Robertson the son of Robertson that
between Amazing Spider-Man 59 and 66
under Nick Spencer's run that what he
had done is crafted this almost kind of
like Romeo and Juliet type story that
when Robbie Robertson right the guy who
works at The Daily Bugle under J Jonah
Jameson when he learned his son was
dating like the daughter of Tombstone
and when Tombstone learned his daughter
was dating the son of Robbie Robertson
each of them tried to get their kids to
stop dating but ultimately they continue
to do so in secret and so with Tombstone
out of the picture once Janice steps up
the whole stance here is you can't just
be here right even Black Mariah says you
can't just take a seat right just
because your pops died doesn't mean that
your seed is now inherited by you every
single one of us has earned a seed at
this table in one form or another
usually by force is really what it is
right demonstrating their power their
capability that kind of thing but the
cool thing about that is Hammerheads
like okay fine if you want to earn a
place at this table then you need to do
what we would do in this situation
you're going to have to kill somebody
close to you in this instance you're
going to have to kill Randy Robertson
now the question is why because in the
aftermath of Kingpin making it illegal
for superheroes to exist in New York it
wasn't a law that could simply just be
overturned by Luke Cage as the new mayor
a vote had to be forced meaning the
people had to basically protest and
advocate for this happening that's what
Randy Robertson was doing behind the
scenes he was literally galvanizing the
public and trying to turn public
sentiment back in favor of superheroes
so superheroes could operate publicly in
the city of New York and so literally
he's working against the entire criminal
Empire so the idea of Hammerhead by
having Janice do this is that one it
makes it almost impossible for her to do
because while they are ex fiances right
like there is still love between the two
of them it's a whole reason why they
didn't get married right it's a whole
great big huge thing but the other part
of this is taking out Randy Robertson
eliminates that right it sends a message
to the public if you try to make
superheroes like legal again will take
you out right and as you guys know the
general public the average person
doesn't quite have the same level of
like resolve or courage or conviction
that superheroes do it's what makes
superheroes stand apart from the general
public so the public would be far more
likely to sort of see this message and
then fall in line out of fear as opposed
to superheroes who would not be
dissuaded now the other part of this is
actually this really cool argument that
takes place between Spider-Man man and
Miles Morales because what you do here
is you transition to a character named
slide whose suit is literally made of a
material that allows him to just move
super quick right it's not an overly
important thing but he is kind of a cool
character to be honest with you guys in
the midst of this Miles Morales shows up
and both he and Peter Parker are able to
overcome slide pretty readily right and
that's it and then following that Miles
just reads Peter Parker the Riot Act and
the reason why is because miles isn't
fully aware of everything that was going
on with Peter being possessed by like
the sins of Norman Osborne all that kind
of stuff but even before then right like
there's a legitimate beef that Miles has
here where he's like you never reached
out you never came to me and said hey
man how's it going you never checked on
me or anything along those lines and
it's one of those funny things about
Peter Parker by and large these stories
were largely confined to like the
conflicts that he had in his personal
life his relationship with Mary Jane
Watson making it to work on time all
that kind of stuff and the Parker luck
was always one of those things where it
was very tongue and cheek a little bit
of Comedy involved where it's just like
man Peter Parker can't get it together
but miles showing up here is like look
we're supposed to be friends and Loosely
teammates in the sense that we're just
like two Spider-Man in the same city
right but it's like you never checked in
at any point you could have and you know
Peter's response is well man I had stuff
going on and it's like everybody has
stuff going on Peter everybody has
things happening Captain America has
things happening Thor has things
happening right like everyone has stuff
going on it's not an excuse to ignore
your friends and it's a really
interesting argument to make here
because for those of you guys who are
older like I am right like I'm 39 those
of you guys who are older you learn that
people sort of fall into these routines
in their lives and often times
maintaining those friendships sort of
gets taken for granted right like well
they're friends I've known for a long
time they'll always be there and that
kind of constant communication like it
was when you were in your 20s going to
the bars all the time different things
like that it begins to go away way right
marriage children the job things like
that all kind of begin to take precedent
and so it's one of those things that
where Peter's not really struggling with
like the normal things that you and I
would struggle with with like a 9 to5 it
doesn't change the fact that the people
in his life feel the effects that Peter
just while he cares doesn't really give
the impression that he does and so it's
one of those interesting things because
in the end he says like I can't believe
that I'm the one that has to like remind
you of this but it seems like you forgot
with great power there must also come
great responsibility feel like you could
do well to remember that and it's an
important thing because the idea of
great responsibility is not confined to
like if you can stop a villain then you
should stop a villain it's if you can
remind your friends that you care and be
there for them when they need you then
you should right so it's a really really
interesting thing because it's just kind
of May was holding a lot of anger and a
lot of resentment towards Peter by
feeling abandoned by him now the reason
why this is also so cool is because
during Brian Michael bis's Spider-Man 2
when Peter and Miles met for the first
time Peter was the one who gave miles
the blessing in the Ultimate Universe to
be that universe's Spider-Man after the
Ultimate Universe version of Peter
Parker had died so there's a very close
connection between the two brothers
mentors whatever you want to call it
right it's a very close connection there
so it's one of the reasons why it hits
mil so hard but at that point you
basically switch over to like Hammerhead
having this conversation with the chick
that he's with right and the cool thing
here is that the question that's asked
by this girl is like do you really think
that like Janice is going to kill Randy
do you really think she can do that and
his response is no she's not going to
because at the end of the day while
she's a villain and she operates by the
mantle of the beetle she's not a killer
right like she's a villain and she'll
rob banks or something along those lines
but she won't kill a guy right she just
can't bring herself to do it and even if
she could she certainly won't be able to
take out Randy because she loves him too
much it's just not going to happen and
that's when he says like I have a
contingency plan it was never the goal
for Janice to kill Randy the goal was
for Janice to lead the henchmen of
hammerhead to Randy and so when that
happens like they go to fire the killing
shot on Janice which is really kind of
like his way of being able to take out
the daughter of Tombstone leaving her
territory open for him to take over and
then take out Randy which eliminates any
concern about superheroes potentially
becoming legal again because the
figurehead for this entire movement
basically dies Randy jumps in the way
and he's injured here now Spider-Man
shows up to Luke Cage who just got the
news and as the two of them are talking
it's one of those things where
Spider-Man's like look I know I've had a
lot going on I heard about what was
going on with Randy I really want to
help but he doesn't know that Randy got
shot what he's saying is I wanted to
help out with Randy in terms of like the
protests and galvanizing public
sentiment towards superheroes being
legal what can I do but that's when he's
told by Luke Cage you don't know yeah
man Randy's been shoted and so what you
do is you jump to the hospital where a
nurse comes running in and talking to
Robbie Robertson about him being shot
realizing oh no it's okay I'm sorry it's
somebody else with the last name
Robertson somebody named Randy only for
Robbie to find out his son's been shot
so he goes running like goes bolting to
the ER where they're literally bringing
Randy in Janice is by his side and the
stance of Robbie is get out of here ever
since he met you his life has gone to
trash you have done nothing but make his
life worse do the best thing like if you
really want to help if you really want
to make this guy's life better leave
disappear and never contact him again he
runs her out of there right which in
truth is actually an accurate statement
despite the love between Janis and Randy
she's only ever made his life worse and
so to a degree Robbie's argument makes
sense here but the other thing that he's
not really considering is like ry's his
own man he knew what he was getting into
so sure to like be associated with
Janice is to live a life of danger but
as far as he was concerned it was a risk
worth taking and so what you do is you
pick up with Hammerhead as well as the
woman that he's with as the two of them
are kind of talking right of course
getting ready to touch naughty bits and
the funny thing about this is she kind
of makes this off-handed remark like you
really kept the mask of Madam mask and
he's like I mean what do you want right
there's not a whole lot of trophies in
our line of work and I'm more or less
the one that orchestrated her being
taken out so yeah of course I'm going to
keep the mask of matam mask it's a huge
trophy to have right like one of the
most significant members of the criminal
underworld yeah man it's like having
Wilson it's like it's like having the
kingpin's cane right it's like a big
thing and so what end up happening is
she kind of asked the question are you
sure that taking out Randy's the right
decision to make here because by taking
him out it's entirely possible that you
end up turning public sentiment away
from legalizing superheroes that fear
gets the better of them or you turn them
into a martyr right and people begin to
see his cause as something that's
greater than themselves and they begin
to fight for it they double down and
they're more zealous than they are
before and so what he ends up doing is
just like grabbing her seizing her
scaring the crap out of her and just
being like are you scared or are you
awake which one is it right and she's
like you know I don't I don't really
know and he's like that's the whole
point it doesn't matter what matters is
you're on the ground and I'm not and
that's because I am exactly as mean as I
need to be which is why I'm in charge of
that room of psychos back there a room
full of killers who want nothing more
than to kill each other and he says the
thing is I'm the reason they want to Ace
each other in the first place then I
give myself the job of keeping
everything from blowing up like grade
AT&T that's what you call job security
the whole idea of hammerhead up to this
point has been orchestrating and seeding
chaos throughout the entirety of the
criminal underground community and then
positioning himself as the guy that
keeps that chaos in order it's actually
incredibly smart and what's so crazy
about that is that it's not dissimilar
from what Kingpin used to do back in the
day but in the midst of all this
literally this girl just like grabs a
pipe and just starts beating him over
the head now normally that wouldn't be
easily done with someone like Hammerhead
hence the reason why he has the name
it's almost nigh indestructible but
literally this thing is just made of
like adamantium and
Magic right you know and so like as
she's kind of taunting him she bashes
his head in and kills this guy right and
that's right when like Janice shows up
and Janice is just kind of like what's
going on here and her response is like I
did what you were going to do but I beat
you to it and that's when Janice puts
two and two together and realizes this
is not some arbitrary person out there
this is Whitney Frost it's Madam mask
that she's just been underground and
masquerading this entire time waiting
for the moment when she could strike and
what Hammerhead had been doing
completely oblivious to the fact that he
was talking to her was spilling the
beans on everything thing that he'd been
doing so now she knows exactly how to
play the field how to take everybody out
and where Janice is just kind of like no
no no no I don't care about any of that
stuff right he had Randy Robertson shot
I just want to take this guy out the
response of Madam mask is you have no
idea what's going on here do you like
you have no real clue what's about to
happen she's like word is going to get
out that Hammerhead is gone that he's
dead no one's territory is safe now
right the treaties he held together will
fall moves will be made seemingly out of
fear but don't be fooled it is greed
opportunity for expansion and
opportunity brings opportunist you're
too young to remember the last land grab
it's thrilling really and she says
watching the Sharks come out anyone who
has a claim past or present they're
going to make a move and so that's when
Janice realizes this is open War that's
literally what it is and so you jump to
Spider-Man meeting with Robbie Robertson
and the two of them having a kind of
heartfelt conversation where
Spider-Man's really kind of talking to
Robbie and Robbie's like you know you
really shouldn't be here right you
should be out there that's what he was
fighting for that kind of thing and
Spider-Man feels very guilty he feels
very sad but the response of Robbie is
no you don't get to feel that right you
don't get to feel those emotions and if
you do feel them you feel them later
your job is to be a superhero your job
is to stand up for what it is that Randy
believed in and to get out there and
fight the good fight but as they're
having this match mive conversation
there's just like all these explosions
that go off across the city of New York
and it's like a full-on war between all
the different Warlords that exist out
there right shangi Black Mariah Mr
negative the whole nine yards it's just
fullscale conflict on the ground level I
would argue this is more significant
than like some threat like some single
guy showing up here because how do you
stop them all right like it's all the
Warlord and all their henchmen all going
to war against one another I'll be
honest man if they did this in like the
Spider-Man PlayStation game wouldn't it
be dope like it's one of the coolest
things ever and so Spider-Man
immediately takes off to meet with Luke
Cage and as the two of them are talking
Luke Cage is like I mean look man it's
not really an Avengers level threat but
I don't know if we have the ability to
take this on right like Spider-Man says
like I'm about to do a whole lot of
superheroing and I don't want
distractions and the response of Luke is
I'm picking up what your putting down
right I will keep the police out of your
way and the response of of Spider-Man is
not my way our way right I need a team
so literally Spider-Man is bringing
together every street level superhero
Spider-Man like like himself Daredevil
Miles Morales Luke Cage the whole nine
yards and they're all going to go to war
against the villains it's why I'm
telling you guys it's the best event
that Marvel has going on that no one is
talking about and it's a amazing but
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end let me know if you
want me to cover the rest of this and
we'll do that alongside the fall of X
and I will catch you all later
peace